the battlefield hardline we really set
out to make a cop show you could play
give it the boot Mendoza
I'm part of the thing that appealed to
me about this game was like just going
all-in on this this is a cop show this
is a TV show these are our actors and
we're gonna film it like a cop show
we're gonna write it like a cop show the
whole story was broken down into
episodes just like a TV season would be
and then each episode had a small
cinematic and that would basically serve
as a previously on for a TV show
previously on hardline that's little ray
says he has information regarding the
drug war that's plaguing my end
one of the things I wanted to see is
that humor could be a part of a
battlefield game against one thing I
really liked about the bad company games
they had lighter tone over an hour maybe
got lost there's a sign on the door that
leads to the tank how hard could it be
hey guys sorry I got lost there's an arc
in each particular episode but there
isn't overall arc and that's the
structure that we followed exactly in
this game as you would on any serious
television show just Nick
Octus isn't welcome here is all about
how the story is caught up the way Colin
henan who's our cinematics wizard at
visceral gets you in and out of the
first-person view he made some super
smart and really artful decisions
throughout the game with Harlan we're
going to try to do something different
and I think we have a great creative
team we had great writers write great TV
people on it I've looked at the call
sheet we had the table reads initially
and it's a big cast and it's a fun cast
it's always amazing sharing stage with
bonito and Kelly and Eugene and Nick I
think the ones where all of us were
together were especially nice the most
fun thing we did on this shoot was
before we shot and that was the tactical
training your job is to keep looking
this direction in case there's a threat
from here he's watching the front
surveying everything it's fun when you
get to be the badass girl those are the
only kind of characters I like to play
bad about does everything you're getting
to meet these characters you're gonna
get a small amount of information about
them but it's just the right amount that
you know them you can relate to them you
like them or you really don't like them
you have no idea who I am because if you
did you would not be stealing from me
and then you're able to jump right into
the action of the game again Harlan
provides a very relatable story I think
that's something that may be hard in
some current military shooters is that
the story is so convoluted because it
goes into political and geopolitical
dynamics here with hardline story it's
all about character so it's much easier
to kind of get attached to them and to
understand what's going on just very
simply what makes stories good are the
characters there are ten episodes in
battlefield hardline and each one of
them has a cop show you'll want play
you